you look like a fun dad i love watching
your videos with your son sasha i will
hold you up high as i stand on a ball
with a book in one hand and a cup on my
hat but that is not all i can do said
the cat
what has been the best part about
fatherhood so far
oh man
it's almost like
i don't know when you hit when you have
a child it um
it pulls everything closer in your life
in terms of the people that you love
your friends it really reveals the
people who really matter in your life um
and it all revolves around this one
special thing that you've created it's
the most incredible thing that's ever
happened to me do you see any of you and
him like your personality of course yeah
i find myself looking at him and getting
like goosebumps because i feel like i'm
like looking at a version of myself
which i guess i am you know and i see a
lot of um clara in him too which is it's
something you can't really describe you
can't really describe the feeling it's
amazing
cheryl
dressed as a ghoulie threw a molotov
cocktail at you it's hard to mistake
cheryl betty no matter what she's
wearing well kj there's some speculation
that riverdale is coming to an end
what are your thoughts on that
um i don't i don't think so i think we
got another season season seven which uh
i know myself and the cast are very
excited about we're gonna be in
vancouver for another year
uh
but yeah not anytime soon we definitely
got at least one more year in front of
us that's a lot of good news that's good
news for a lot of people okay well some
people are just kind of getting into
riverdale so how would you explain the
multiverse for those people it's
complicated
it's definitely it's definitely
complicated we have been through the
ringer we've done a lot since the start
of the show i know we have a lot of
loyal fans who have been there from the
very beginning which is why we love
coming to paley fest and all the comic
cons
but
over the last year over the course of
this season
we have things from you know for archie
he's developed a certain type of gift
um
invulnerability
and uh
you know which comes with its benefits
and
he's stronger than the average person
i'll say maybe not stronger than the
hulk but uh he's strong
so
yeah we're playing with some fun kind of
elements this season when you first
signed on to the show did you ever thank
your character not at all i don't think
any of us super power no i don't think
so but it's always it's it's fun man you
never know what we're gonna get thrown
at from the writers so it's everything's
it's super fun well looking back over
the last past five years what would be
the lesson or the piece of advice you
would tell yourself when you first
started on this show
a piece of advice from when i first
started would be
i feel like with archie because he's so
serious all the time and which is great
i feel like just this season i've
started to have a little more fun with
the character in terms of
lightening him up a little bit
um
you know which does bring back spikes of
like the pilot episode as well but i
feel like i would i would say to just
have more fun with it because i feel
like
that's what helps get us through a lot
of the workload and being in vancouver
for 10 months of the year
finding the fun in the work is what what
keeps you going i feel like we are six
seasons into riverdale is there still
something on your bucket list that you
want archie to accomplish or to
experience
um
it would be cool for him to settle down
get married
um
maybe have a kid i don't know
[Music]
you